the west has promised to continue
tightening economic sanctions on moscow
as part of efforts to deter the russian
president
but could more be done
cities have been destroyed lives lost
and evidence has emerged to suggest war
crimes have been committed
at what point does the west say mr putin
has gone too far
i'm trevor phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
tonight nearly seven weeks on from the
invasion of ukraine our viewers panel
from across the country and indeed
across the world
will have their say
they'll tell their stories
while joining us here in the studio this
week are lord ricketts the uk's former
national security advisor and former
british ambassador to nato
uk director of human rights watch yasmin
ahmed
chair of the commons defense select
committee tobias elwood
and from washington melinda herring
deputy director of the atlantic
council's eurasia center
the question facing us all tonight
is the west letting putin get away with
it
you can see what's left of the missile
just to focus on the words on the side
of that missile zadetti it means for the
children
the attack at the train station in
eastern ukraine shows the depths to
which putin's once vaunted army has sunk
we will see more examples of killing of
civilians which are war crimes
russia's crimes in ukraine will not go
unpunished
a mass grave for what ukraine has called
a massacre
they've been shot in the head with a
tight hands behind their back
we deny that russian military
can have something in common with these
atrocities
did some sort of
huge
conspiracy a propaganda stunt do you
realize how grotesque that sounds it's
not a conspiracy actually it's a bold
fake
the kremlin may want the world to
believe this is fake news
but the evidence of russia's rampage
is all too real
okay let's start as ever with our
viewers panel and talk to anton ivashik
anton
what has been your experience
um okay can you hear me well we can hear
you perfectly well go ahead cool
so um
my family lived
in bucha before
[Music]
the active state of war before the war
came to bucha
and
[Music]
it came
early in
february 24
and we tried to analyze everything and
we decided to stay
in our house
actually now we know that that was
wrong solution
but we decided to stay as well as the
family of my sister
uh she lived in bucha as well
so
um
fightings were
mainly
ear fightings
where
everywhere we bucha is located um
close to
the stonewall airport
and that was their target for that day
and
fightings were
everywhere
so
we
decided to leave butcher
the next day
february
25
and that was very good solution because
uh we
left butcher
at the middle of the day and um
after that
some street
uh became
let's go to olenna let's go
hello trevor good evening elena um can
you hear me well we can hear you
perfectly well i think you've got a
a comment and a thought and a question
for our studio panel i do
first of all i want to say thank you to
anton for sharing his experience with us
and he's an example of thousands of
innocent ukrainians who have been forced
out of their homes and much worse
i have been attending daily protests at
trafalgar square and downing streets in
the start of the war and together with
our london activities i have organized a
project outside of russian embassy last
week
we have been demanding more significant
action and more help from the west
and if the war crimes in bucha kramators
mariupol and other places do not make
the world intervene it really breaks my
heart to think nothing will
the west must act now
we need to disarm russia on the ground
in the air and in the media and it is
important that western media does not
provide a platform to propaganda
spreaders like esco
so for now uh my question to the panel
is
when will the west say enough it's
enough and take reaction against russia
wellina thank you so much for that uh
very direct question there from
elena leotraska and that question to our
panel is
when will the west say enough is enough
and take real action against russia
peter ricketts
well enough is enough and i think the
west has been acting uh we have been
arming ukraine with more and more uh
advanced weapons
but to stop russia
to disarm russia
to apply a no-fly zone to russia would
mean nato going to war with russia i
mean that's i'm afraid the stark reality
of the position
i think that the west is prepared to do
everything short of that economic
sanctions military support
but let's not um
underplay the risk of any nato military
action against russian forces in
ukraine is that
isn't that tantamount to saying
in truth
all we can do is watch ukraine
lose
slowly
no it's not saying that because we have
played our part in allowing the
ukrainian forces to defend so
effectively against the russians they've
been magnificently brave
and part of the reason they've been
successful is very modern western
weapons and the economic sanctions on
russia will also play
but i do not think that western leaders
are ready to take their countries into
direct war with russia
with all the risks that come with that
including right at the end of the
spectrum the possibility even of putin
using nuclear weapons melinda herring
so i think lord ricketts had a point
last week but the situation has changed
so phase one is over vladimir putin
tried to take over ukraine for six weeks
and he failed he only got one city the
city of her son that's it there were
massive losses of life on the russian
side the russians got their butts kicked
just to summarize uh and they have
withdrawn to belarus into the dawn boss
we expect them to make a major push in
the don boss this week but the the way
that the war is going to happen in the
don boss is going to be different than
it was in the first phase the second
phase i'm sorry to say favors the
russians because ukrainians don't have
the same kind of uh they don't have the
same kind of multiple launch rocket
systems and the kind of gear that russia
has which is why defense minister
reznikov from the ukrainian side is
begging for additional gear so i think
lord ricketts was right up to a point
but that's no longer true now we must do
more now and there's a real tipping
point uh
this this point in the don boss is going
to be very very crucial ukraine or
russia has about two to three months
left of capable uh military men if the
ukrainians can wage war and hold their
territory they can get a real deal at
the negotiating table but much depends
on what happens in the donbas melinda
thank you i'm going to come back in
studio in a moment and ask if time's
running out but i want to talk to our
viewers panel again and come to paul
peachey
paul
what do you think
is vladimir putin being led off the hook
well if your p is put in he will never
stop so we must have all we can to stop
him and stop him as quickly as possible
now in my view the um the uk has been
leading the response to this war i'm no
fan of the prime minister
but he is showing leadership now he's
being decisive
um
timely
effective
thank you very much paul tobias ellwood
that's an interesting point isn't it
prime minister made a big gesture this
weekend and actually put some
guns literally behind it
but
what do you think about melinda's point
that actually the situation now is so
different
it may not be enough yeah we are moving
into i'm afraid an uglier phase of uh
this war this uh
invasion uh russian troops are removing
themselves from the north but there as
we we've just heard they're uh then
pushing into the donbass area and
probably into the odessa area too if the
port of odessa falls then the ukraine's
grain uh which is so critical for us the
world won't be able to get out and
ukraine's economy then will fall what i
would say is that putin took a gamble on
uh whether his troops could actually
take over ukraine clearly that wasn't
going to happen i was in the country a
week before the invasion and there was
an absolute determination for the
ukrainian people to stay and fight and
they asked me the question will nato be
there to support us we're part of europe
where you're uh your european democracy
and he putin was spot on in recognizing
that there will be timidity there'll be
a risk averseness of nato not willing to
step in and we're now seeing the
consequences of our hesitance and we
need to become bolder create a
sort of a cold war statecraft capability
to stand up to putin knowing that there
is an escalatory ladder but also knowing
that if we don't support ukrainians
don't stop putin now it won't stop in
ukraine it will go further that's the
bigger picture security challenge that
we now face we we've entered a new era
of insecurity we've got to wake up to
that
there's a lot of support on the wall for
that view as to expressed by tobias but
yazmin
ahmed
do you accept melinda's point that we've
perhaps reached a tipping point now
where the rules
that everybody agreed
eight days ago
cannot apply going forward
well certainly uh from human rights
watch perspective we have been
documenting the uh violations and war
crimes apparent war crimes that are
being committed on the ground so we have
been uh in a number of these cities and
obviously we saw as the russians
withdrew some from some of the areas
that they were occupying some horrendous
scenes including uh evidence of uh you
know summary executions sexual violence
and rape uh torture and and other such
things so i think certainly what we're
seeing now is a an escalation in terms
of also the human suffering on the
ground and certainly it's one thing from
our perspective
as human rights watches and to ensure
that the evidence
about what is happening and by whom
is collated collected and preserved for
any future accountability i'm going to
come to stephen fairley stephen
um
another friend of the program uh stephen
what what do you think
i mean i've listened to the comments
tonight i mean my my views on it was
that you know i feel that we are doing
as much as we can without
actually putting boots on the ground
listening to the comments it's sort of
swaying me a little bit towards
as the more we can do um i know that we
have focused in any in this side of
europe
on sanctions and what i was thinking was
the sanctions have only been in place
primarily maybe five six weeks i know
the war started maybe seven weeks ago
but we started putting the sanctions and
they must i mean we knew i mean
boris was saying for weeks and weeks
before russia invaded to try to invade
ukraine that it was happening so russia
had a lot of money put by
to fund this war
and we can't expect
russia to to run out of money so quickly
i mean we have to wait and see if the
sanctions are actually going to impact
them and it looks like it may be doing
that as we're going forward
it still it still doesn't mean that
we're doing the right thing with regards
to
putting boots in the ground etc but i
think
the sanctions need to be i mean we're
still there's still 200 banks in the
world who are still taking money
on behalf of russia for
oil and gas okay why why are these banks
still taking money from european
countries why are they not being started
thank you stephen
peter i think this is a difficult
piece of territory and it's a difficult
judgment to make
but um and take stephen i think broadly
would support what you said
but do you see the point that's being
made that actually maybe the game has
changed the circumstances have changed
enough
for us to
essentially accept greater risk than we
might have done a month ago well i
absolutely agree that the situation has
changed and i agree that we're now
moving into a even worse phase if that's
possible for the people of ukraine as
the fighting moves into the donbass i
think melinda is quite right we need to
be making a step change in what we are
giving the ukrainian armed forces heavy
artillery
better weapons longer-range missiles and
so on so they can go on being effective
but i think we've got to be really clear
what we mean by doing more and stepping
up if we mean actually taking the war to
russia in ukraine by nato then that
risks
russian missiles on nato territory and
we're on the escalatory ladder upwards
so i think we've got to absolutely step
up our support for ukraine give them the
most modern weapons we can forget this
old distinction that used to be between
defensive weapons and offensive weapons
this is all about self-defense of people
in ukraine but i do think that there is
a difference between that and actually
sending nato troops to fight russians in
ukraine
melinda um
was your point earlier on really not so
much that we want nato boots on the
ground there's i don't think there's any
possibility of that but was it about the
weight of weaponry uh i think there's a
distinction people are making at the
moment about light defensive weapons and
heavy weapons for example planes
um that could be used essentially by the
ukrainians themselves
that's exactly right i think you have to
go to harvard law school to see the fine
distinction between escalatory weapons
and defensive weapons this is nonsense
when you're on the battlefield in
ukraine uh they need as many weapons as
possible uh the systems that they're
requesting now in particular our s-300s
the air defense systems they need planes
they don't have very many they need
tanks they need anti-ship missiles
drones and then long-range artillery
missiles for this next phase this is the
great debate up next has the
international community done enough to
deter putin
[Applause]
together with our allies and our
partners we're going to keep raising the
economic cost and ratchet up the pain
for putin
the un human rights council has voted to
suspend russia he was a permanent member
of that human rights council
they have no right even to say human
rights
and with this situation i think we are
very much welcome very close
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm hannah thomas peter and i'm skye's
climate change correspondent
the uk is a world leader in wind power
[Music]
it's part of the congo basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of africa
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me i might be just very
naive but i do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
i'm confident for the last 30 years we
have known how bad it is
i'm not here to apologize i'm here to
fight for the next step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these this sofas and people's
desks and children's books and you can
see inside this home here people trying
to uh
to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
i think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of the beauty
around us
the future
of you and me
[Music]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
organism
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
this week we're asking
is the west letting vladimir putin get
away with it
after the horrors of the second world
war there were two organizations which
emerged to prevent anything like it
happening again nato and the united
nations promised peace in europe
but now face accusations of impotence in
the face of putin's aggression
ukraine's president has regularly called
on nato the world's most powerful
military alliance for support
and while some countries have answered
that request a coordinated response
appears out of the grasp of the
ukrainian government
let's jump straight back in with our
viewers panel i want to go
to
our friend david mccormack dave good
evening
good morning what's your thought on this
point about international organizations
well all i see is that united nations
and nato seem to have meeting upon
meeting
to discuss further meetings
pre-meetings before the main meeting and
then post meetings to discuss what was
said in the main meeting
all nato has done is tell pewter what
they won't do
they are and have been helpless to stop
and put an end to this war
meanwhile
all the time bombs and bullets are
killing ukrainians
atrocities are being committed on a
scale not yet truly uncovered
their country and properties have been
decimated and ukrainian families
disbanded all over the globe
so
it begs the question
has this war expose nato and the united
nations as to whether they are relevant
and effective
for a global crisis of this magnitude in
today's world or do they vastly need big
reform
thank you very much dave well that's
pretty direct let's uh bring it back to
the studio
has this war exposed nato and the united
nations as to whether they are relevant
and effective in a global crisis of this
magnitude in today's world
tobias elwood i think absolutely right i
think our international rules-based
order is being tested
it's worked well for the last few
decades but it's now completely wobbly
and it easily is abused by both russia
and china and this is the tipping point
i think we need uh to recognize there's
something called the thucydides trap
which is where a superpower is then
challenged for its base for its power by
an emerging power and this is china
which in our lifetimes will militarily
technologically economically grow bigger
than uh the united states it's not liked
the international rules based order it's
teamed up with russia russia would not
have invaded ukraine had it not had the
backing of china we in the west need to
wake up and recognize that ukraine is
just one part of this bigger jigsaw the
united nations is a great example of an
international rules-based organization
unable to hold errant nations to account
in fact that china abuses these
organizations it abused the w ah ho the
world health organization most
critically the world trade organization
as well the west needs to wake up and
stand up and repair these organizations
peter ricketts um
wow well you s that tobias elwood has
just destroyed most of your life's work
by the sound of it um the rules based
order we need him bust well and dave
makes a very powerful point uh but i
would draw a distinction between the un
and nato the united nations set up in
1945 in order to get the soviet union
and the americans on board had to accept
this idea of a veto for the major powers
and so russia has a veto in the security
council and so if there's an issue that
concerns russia or another permanent
member of the council the un is on the
sidelines that's absolutely right it
can't work because it's timid
it's still useful as a sounding board
for international opinion nato
i i think dave is wrong to say nato has
done nothing
nato this organization of 30 countries
that are committed to helping each other
out if one is attacked they've pushed at
least 40 000 troops further forward
towards russia they've strengthened all
the countries around russia in a way
that putin certainly would never have
wanted but putin has drawn this down on
himself so nato is stronger and more
united but nato's job is to defend nato
allies it's not nato's job to go in and
fight russia in ukraine okay so far no
supporters of the united nations in this
studio but let's let's go back to the
panel and talk to
uh michaelo uh winitsky uh michaela
where where do you stand on this do you
think the international institutions
have done their job
well first of all let me say that um
i'm in ukraine um i'm south of cave at
the moment and i've been living through
this war personally and i think that
it's much more important for us to be
talking about the fantastic job that's
being done by the ukrainians on the
ground
then to be talking about
who's to blame the united nations or
nato etc uh nato countries have been
helping ukraine we are very grateful for
that but at the end of the day we
understand that this is our war to fight
we will and we have been victorious we
have been doing exceptionally well we
would very much ask for more weaponry we
understand that this is our war to win
now having said that having said that
there is one point that i want to make
very soon and this is this is important
because
nato as lord ricketts has said very
correctly nato is protecting its own
eastern flank now i was always under the
impression that nato not only protected
its eastern flank but nato and and
protected this idea of european values
and this idea of democracy and freedom
melinda
i'm going to come back to i want to talk
to yasmin about this issue of values but
before we do that
where what's your view about the way
that particularly
the united nations
has done its job here
so
i have zero expectations for the un so
you know i i can't evaluate them i think
the big disappointment and the big story
that we missed is how poorly nato has
done uh they've made a number of
mistakes yes there's great unity but
that's about all you can say so they are
scared to they should have put a
permanent rotation of troops in eastern
europe a long time ago they did not move
enough troops to deter putin they talked
about it they moved a few uh they had a
meeting recently and they wrote a a you
know a hand clinging statement that said
nothing and they kicked the can down the
road until june uh i expected a lot more
from nato and i think the big story the
scary thing is there was a an essay that
came out today an interview in an
italian paper and it's with vladimir one
of vladimir putin's closest advisors and
he basically says that uh russia is not
afraid of article five guarantees and
that once they destroy ukraine they're
going to europe next and i was trevor i
was very skeptical of this claim i
thought that that vladimir putin was
afraid of of article 5 and the nato
guarantees uh the the but it's it seems
like he's not anymore and you know
vladimir putin is not the same man he
was when he came into office at the end
of 99 there's a lot of speculation that
he's sick i don't know if that's true or
not but he's definitely erratic thank
you
on our viewers panel natalie bowers in
east sussex
natalie do you think that the
international communities institutions
could have done more
to prevent us getting to where we are
now
thanks trevor well i'm taking a slightly
different position on this one and i do
agree though reform is needed um but i
think nato have been strengthened by the
unity that they've shown in the face of
aggression towards a country which is
outside of nato albeit on the border um
it does seem to me that the u.n of and
specifically the security council have
got the tougher job because of course
russia is one of the five states with
the power of veto and so i can't see how
they can move much beyond condemnation
and humanitarian aid thank you very much
indeed i i want to um
just stay there let's go to tarik
ali uh tariq
what's your view
um
following on from the previous points as
russia is a member of the security
council and it has the veto powers
the council cannot recommend the removal
of russia without its agreement
effectively russia would need to approve
its own sacking
bit like asking turkeys to vote for
christmas
russia's veto makes a complete mockery
of the united nations security council
what the panel's opinions please
thank you very much
yasmin um
if nothing else the international
institutions particularly united nations
it's supposed to be there it's got human
rights council all the rest of it
to protect people from brutality torture
and so on
not much success in the last month or
two is it
well i think as sir peter noted very
rightly uh the fact that you have russia
on the security council means that
taking any decisive action is extremely
difficult
but what we have seen in fact is the un
um and other international bodies in
fact mobilizing faster and states
mobilizing faster and more
severely in this context than in other
contexts so in fact while it's not
enough what we've certainly seen we've
seen
the human rights council was established
a commission of inquiry which will hold
and preserve evidence for future trials
we've seen the international criminal
court open investigation into crimes so
what we have seen actually is certain
and very uh very quick action in respect
of ukraine but obviously there are
questions about whether this is enough
in relation to the situation puerto
ricans the uh actually i think the
united nations united council kicked
russia off off the council didn't it
suspended it yeah um which is obviously
right because it's a mockery to have
russia on a human rights council which
is a selection of un members supposed to
be upholding human rights um but i think
it's inevitably the case that if one
permanent member of the u.n a major
country nuclear-armed country is riding
roughshod over the rules and ignoring
them then there's not a lot the security
council can do about it but the un has
this attraction this value which is it's
universal it's the place where global
public opinion can be focused on an
issue and i think therefore to kick
russia out would be a mistake because i
think in the end we will need to be able
to focus global opinion on russia
okay this is the great debate coming up
the fight to keep the russian people
informed about the reality of the war
five seconds on state tv that millions
will have watched
[Music]
protesting inside russia tends not to
end up well
ukraine's enemies are heroes here in
russia's towns and villages as the
country's losses grow oh yes nazis
nazistitum
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the great debate and we're
asking
is the west letting putin get away with
it
since russia's invasion in february the
world's media have been telling the
stories of ukrainians caught in the
conflict
but for the people of russia there's
just one version of events available the
one permitted by the kremlin
by shutting down independent news
outlets and barring social media mr
putin controls the narrative around what
is happening in ukraine
earlier in this series we heard from
constantine a russian living in the
united kingdom constantine told us how
his family and friends believed that
russian troops were saving ukrainians
from a nazi regime
he joins us again tonight uh
constantine
have they changed their mind at all
um unfortunately not um the propaganda
in russia is still staying strong um
we you know russian people who live
outside of the country you know
protesting or donating to you know to
the causes against the war
um
we try to get to the minds of people
inside the country try to speak to them
but it's been extremely difficult
um to the point where i for example had
to cut off relationships with some of
the friends when you've decades because
you know this war is a red line it's not
something that you can accept
unfortunately any longer um so it's
still extremely difficult
do you um
how would you sum this up do you have a
question for our panels on this question
if i may i have a question about um how
can the west fight this information
award the propaganda in russia
thank you very much for that constantine
let's see what our panel thinks
how can the west fight the information
war in russia
melinda
what can we do
thanks trevor first of all constantine
i'm really proud of you for standing up
and using your voice i we need more um
courageous russians to do the same so i
think the west needs to get real about
the size and scope of this problem and
put real money behind a russian language
television station probably based in
berlin somewhere in europe and this
would be run by people who know how to
make real russian language television
the attempts that i've seen are pretty
wimpy and the content is not very good
uh so this would be this idea is to
bring all the western uh governments
together and put real money uh behind a
big project and this isn't a three-year
project this is a 10 or 20-year project
to be able to message to the russian
people and not only do news stories but
also do human interest stories
and give them real unvarnished news in
the russian language yes mean
how could we change
at least give the russian people a
diversity of pic of narratives
well yeah i mean the situation in russia
now is the worst it's been in decades in
terms of repression so this is what
we're seeing is we've seen a crackdown
on all media all western media
are out we've seen our russian media
outlets have to close twitter and
facebook have been banned in fact
facebook has been declared to be an
extremist organization and what we've
also seen is thousands of people have
been arrested and detained for merely
protesting and we know that
you'll be in jail for 15 years for
merely mentioning the word war so
there's an unprecedented suppression of
people in russia now i think western
governments and all governments around
the world have an obligation to be
supporting russian civil society to the
extent that they can whether that's like
the panel has said whether that's
through media particular media outlets
also very importantly i think is
providing safety for people in russia
who who want to seek asylum regularizing
their status in the uk extending visas
we should be making sure that we are
providing a safe haven and we are
providing ample opportunity for people
to hear the messages and to be able to
speak freely and to be able to hear and
listen to messages all right let's uh
talk to alexandra i think
alexander you can tell us about what is
happening in belarus
uh yes good evening i see myself as
ukrainian as i spent most of my life
there but i'm russian by birth
uh when i contacted my cousin from
moscow he said that my view on the war
is just alternative but he believes the
russian version of the war
but my sister from belarus though is
crying over the loss of life in
this war and she's saying the war is the
wrong thing she gets information from
different sources but anyway she rather
leans towards russian view on the war
including russian version that the
photos from bucha are staged by
hollywood and it has been so painful for
us to communicate on that
that finally we had to stop talking
about ukraine at all which i'm not sure
is the best decision in this case
because i still hope to
tell the truth to her
uh how powerful and far-reaching the
propaganda is is so shocking and i don't
know what we can do to get through to
people to make them see the truth
thank you alexandra tobias
i mean
we've talked a bit about weaponry but
actually the length of this conflict
is dependent to some extent on what the
russian people are prepared to tolerate
um
this information war does matter doesn't
it well i would disagree with that i was
shocked when i heard jan stoltenberg the
head of nato say we must prepared
be prepared for this war to go on years
we can't accept that we must help the
ukrainians defeat russia in ukraine by
whatever means that are absolutely
required without this escalating out of
control i think there was this
assumption that with the the might of
the sanctions that went in that somehow
putin uh would be uh in a coup would
take place or he'd be purged he'd be out
i think in the long term that probably
will be the case that's how the cold war
ended not because of the west pressure
but because their own economy eventually
collapsed but putin is there to stay for
the moment could we do better on this in
this war
uh we can certainly do better by
widening the scope of it yes absolutely
and i think other countries around the
world like india like south africa even
like china have to understand that there
are big issues at stake here and that to
see a country smashing its neighbor in
the way russia is doing is a real threat
to the rules that all countries need to
live by and all benefit from so yes we
need to do that and i think the
information war is crucial putin has
tried really hard to keep the truth out
of russia because putin is afraid of the
truth and he's built a firewall around
russia but we have all kinds of
techniques in our gchqs cyber techniques
and so on i'm sure we should be using
them to try and get the truth in by
social media by the bbc world service
any other way we can because the truth
is a big danger to putin and there must
be a whole generation of young russians
who don't know what's going on but are
potentially capable of being opponents
if they know let's go back to the wall
and talk to cassenya
um
and we're not giving your surname
what do you think about this issue of
how
russian opinion
is informed more effectively
well that's a difficult question and of
course you know it goes back not only to
the last 20 years that putin has been
building this dictatorship system that
includes not only media but all other
institutions including government courts
police that all fall under one vertical
of power that responds to only him but
it's also i think uh is in our cultural
dna historically you know to
have
been through
a long period of the authoritarian
regime of the soviet union
and i think russians a lot of them the
majority of them do not have the luxury
of being able to think critically to
voice their opinion or to stand up
against the regime or against putin like
many people in the western world
see it it's not as simple as it might
seem to be i think a dose of reality
there
you're watching the great debate up next
is the west standing
on the right side of history
[Applause]
[Music]
x has been for some time
a permitted
option and
in accordance with the international
standards but
it's up it's been uh
down to individual nations if they want
to
actually incorporate the ex into their
own policy
and some countries chose to do that at
an early stage like new zealand
australia
more recently canada malta
and a number of countries in south
america colombia
argentina
uruguay and now the states which i think
will hopefully be a game changer whether
that will make the uk
government see sense and and uh
and get on the right side of history
remains to be seen but
i i've gone as far as i can
in the legal system in this country and
so with my legal team and i are going to
be now
taking the case to strasbourg although
strasbourg wouldn't be able to undo
the
uk ruling as it were but i'm hoping that
it might be a wake-up call for for
countries that haven't and i don't think
there's anywhere that i know of that has
been as slow to act as the uk
where this issue has been raised because
most governments can
seem to accept that there is a need for
for ex passports and and it's something
that is basically
very uncontroversial in that it doesn't
harm anybody else it's just giving
people such as myself that
i do not identify as male or female it
means that i'd be able to have a neutral
passport that wouldn't force me to
declare
an inappropriate gender and had to carry
that that
passport that document around which is
supposed to be
an identity document and it has a
gendered reference that i don't identify
with and to me that that's fundamentally
wrong
i'm hinderman rasheed and i'm sky's
north of england correspondent telling
stories from this culturally rich region
i call home
[Music]
[Music]
organized
[Music]
is the west letting vladimir putin get
away with it that's the topic of the
great debate this week
history doesn't repeat itself but it
sometimes rhymes
reports of alleged war crimes in ukraine
recall recent memories of genocide in
eastern europe
and europe as a whole vowed never to see
the atrocities of world war ii repeated
but as shocking images emerge from
places like butcher and kramatorsks
calls for action against putin and his
forces grow stronger
let's speak to the viewers panel and
talk to jackie skip
jackie
hi trevor
currently putin is just ignoring all
international rules
the way he's inflicting unimaginable
suffering
and committing atrocities against
ukrainians
i feel that there has to be some sort of
retribution um
for the war crimes and i wanted to ask
is there any way a peacekeeping force
could now be put on the ground to
prevent genocide
thank you jackie tobias elwood you've
been
uh in the aftermath at least of this
kind of conflict what do you think yeah
i served under the u.n banner and
it's premature to think of a pc
peacekeeping force coming in you need
normally agreements on all sides that
normally happens once a truce has been
confirmed if you were bold about it if
we were more assertive about it then you
could as i touched on earlier have a
peacekeeping force that takes over a
humanitarian safe haven around the port
of odessa for example or those nuclear
power plants that we saw we didn't want
them to be hit by anything again the un
could have actually isolated those a
plume of anything coming out of there if
that was hit would end up almost
breaching article 5 wandering across and
causing damage in the west i make the
point though that ask yourself what
putin is trying to do in ukraine what
does success look like in ukraine until
you answer that question then you can't
even place a un peacekeeping force there
the bigger issue that we face is this
turning point in the next 30 years or so
of this axis between russia and china we
talked earlier about the international
rules based order they're not interested
in it they want to rewrite it
authoritarianism doesn't sit well with
the international rules based order we
want more transparency more democracy
more openness that's exactly what
president xi and president putin don't
want so we need to recognize stockholm
putin in ukraine let me finish it's so
important otherwise this will go to
moldova it'll go to bosnia back to
georgia and then probably north uh as
well
i i do want to address this question of
if you like long-term history but this
i'm going to come to you melinda and
i'll ask you do you think that there is
any space at all
for in between where we are now
and where what peter ricketts said
earlier in the program
uh more or less described as the
catalyst for a
uh confrontation
that leads us to world war iii is there
a place in which something like a
peacekeeping force could protect people
without triggering
uh world conflict and
nuclear weapons and all of that
unfortunately no
there's no way that you can put a
peacekeeping mission in place right now
it's been tried a couple of times to put
humanitarian quarters in and the
russians just shoot at those people if
you look at mariopol which is down in
southeastern ukraine it's been heavily
shelled the city's destroyed now they
can't get humanitarian
vehicles in the russians simply won't
let them and there's horrific accounts
of the russians kidnapping children from
mariopol and sending them into russia
proper it's just not possible unless
there's a real ceasefire and russia
respects the rules and it doesn't okay
let's go back to vs panel and talk to
annika cover
anri
what do you make of this is there any
way through this that you can see
so i'm actually from georgia and my
parents are from the region called
abhasia which was occupied by russia
in 1992
and upon the russian occupation my
great-grandparents they were actually
murdered in a massacre
and these types of war crimes are being
committed are very similar to what's
going on currently and what's been going
on in the past few weeks in bucharest
so the fact that there's been about 30
years between what's going on in georgia
and what's going on today in bucharest
and there's been no real change in the
russian
uh actions
is is quite heartbreaking to see like is
is is
horrifying to be honest
stay there henry um
yasmin
a warning
from the past really
that we've been here before
yeah absolutely and i think obviously
there are there are many lessons that
need to be learned um but also what has
been learnt is the importance of
ensuring that uh that that we uh
document and that we uh uh ensure that
the crimes that are being committed
there is accountability for those crimes
both as a deterrent but also for the
victims of those crimes peter rickers
this history this issue of being on the
right wrong side of history tobias
elwood
projected a future in which essentially
big states russia and china who don't
really care very much about
rules-based order
essentially say
we're going to be in charge
if we're in an alliance or
in partnership or whatever we're going
to run stuff if we can is that where we
are
well that's what i spent my entire
career trying to avoid certainly i think
the history he's talking to look back
and say we didn't do enough to deter
putin in years gone by so when putin
invaded georgia we were in the middle of
the financial crash and and there wasn't
a very strong reaction uh when he went
into the east of ukraine there were some
reactions but not enough to deter him i
think that's a fair cop but i think now
honestly the west has woken up i think
the reaction has been far stronger than
putin expected it hasn't stopped him the
killing but it has posed enormous cost
and we have thwarted his effort to
overturn the government of ukraine
now the west has to take its role much
more seriously look at a country like
germany massively now increasing its
defence spending taking its role as a
major power much more seriously i think
the countries of the west but also
include australia japan many others that
have an interest in the rules-based
system need to come together and be much
more effective in the future in dealing
with these authoritarian regimes
thank you all
and that is all that we have time for
this evening and indeed for this series
of the great debate
jeff remains for me to thank our
panelists tobias elwood yazmin ahmed
peter ricketts
and melinda herring
and of course i want to thank
our viewers panel for their
contributions tonight and indeed most of
you for your contributions through this
series which has frankly made this show
such a fantastic experience i'm really
grateful to you
and of course
you at home
thank you for watching we'll see you
back here in the autumn for a next
another series of the great debate
[Music]
[Applause]